hello little turtles in octopi coffee on
a Tuesday and vlog 54 at night I often
wonder and what I imagine is not an
uncommon reverie if there are aliens out
there on planets orbiting distant stars
looking up and wondering the exact same
thing if they have evolved like us to
build massive powerful telescopes they'd
of course see turning the lens in our
direction the great spiral that is the
Milky Way a kind of motion in celestial
stillness but that's not all they'd sue
mning out a bit more they'd catch a pair
of bright clouds looking almost like
children chasing each other in empty
space around their parent galaxies older
and larger sibling would appear about
1/10 as bright as the Milky Way and the
smaller sibling about 1/4 as bright as
that these are the Magellanic Clouds
just 2 of over a dozen satellite
galaxies orbiting the Milky Way what
makes these 2 so distinct is that unlike
their brethren they're still alive with
the materials necessary for making stars
in fact the larger Magellanic Cloud is
so fertile it boasts the largest stellar
nursery in our local group beating out
the vastly bigger Andromeda galaxies and
even our own Milky Way
most galactic satellites are dead in
this respect the gargantuan
gravitational force of the parent galaxy
usually robs them of their gas in a
process known as tidal stripping without
gas there can be no stars these dark
dwarf spheroidal czar the haunted houses
of a galactic subgroup so faintly do
they move across the sky that the first
one discovered the sculptor dwarf in
1938 was mistaken for a fingerprint on a
photographic plate why then are the
Magellanic Clouds still viable while new
data from the Hubble is starting to
reveal some clues Yale astronomer
Nietzsche Callie viola whose name I've
just murdered says that they're likely
passing us for the very first time this
means their orbits once thought to be
one to two billion years around the
Milky Way might be much much longer they
only got close to us it seems some 200
million years ago which is to say just
now for all that
previous time they were as the man says
[Applause]
indeed an astronomer named Gerty nabela
from Columbia University thinks that the
smaller cloud actually smashed right
through the larger initiating an
accelerated star creation and leaving
many of its own stars behind and you
know as was reading this article in
Scientific American from which I learned
many of these things I had a thought I
was thinking how noteworthy it is that
the mechanics of nature so mimicked the
emotional mechanics of our lives I mean
have you ever smashed right into
somebody have you ever moved through
someone and not afterwards retained some
of their own stars do we not like these
brilliant clouds leave a trail of
ourselves in the wake of our movement
through the world
what is this parallelism between nature
and humanity I began to think the mighty
heaven says the philosopher Proclus
exhibits in its transfigurations clear
images of the splendor of intellectual
perceptions and as the magellanic clouds
move closer in their transit to the
Milky Way the nearer is pulled away from
its partner and left at such a distance
as would make it impossible for the
dance to continue the lesser fractured
from its earlier collision will hurtle
in the dark to a gasless fate an empty
nursery some haunted fingerprint on a
photographic plate
loosely
seeing for
[Music]
they may need the universe is the
external of the soul wherever the life
is that bursts into appearance around it
our science is sensual and therefore
superficial the earth and the heavenly
bodies physics and chemistry we
sensually treat as if they were self
existent but these are the retinue of
the being that we have Emerson the poet